in Ukraine this is what victory day
looks like on the anniversary of the
Allies victory over the Nazis
78 years later another war is being
waged
almost the same parties of World War II
but this time the lineup and the roles
are different the enemy of yesterday is
today's Ally Germany is providing
Military Support to Ukraine and its war
against Russia
unfortunately on this day we have to
draw parallels between the second world
war and Russia's barbaric war of
aggression on Ukraine ukrainians made an
important contribution to freeing Europe
from Nazi rule
president zelinski suggests this country
should celebrate v-day on May 8th in
line with European allies until now it's
marked on May the 9th alongside Russia
[Music]
before then and we fight now so that no
one ever again enslaves other nations or
destroys other countries and all those
old evils that modern Russia is bringing
back will be defeated just as Nazism was
defeated
they differ on almost everything but
Russians and ukrainians unite on
comparing their enemy to the Nazis
I want to talk to the brotherly
Ukrainian people who are poisoned with
Nazism by the Americans who provide them
with weapons to destroy Ukraine and the
Russian World
while Moscow and other Russian cities
are Awash With Victory Flags
celebrations have been downscaled due to
security concerns after a multiple drone
attack on the Kremlin this is Moscow
City's first encounter with the
liabilities of its latest War